- Going in to a big client meeting.
See how it goes.
Did we get anything today?
(bouncy, electronic music)
You know I'm gonna throw you
a little bit of a curve ball.
First of all, that's 100% right.
I made enough dollars
a long time ago and I don't
mean some of the cool stuff,
I mean, when I made $100,000 a year
I literally thought I'd made it.
- [Man] Sure.
- You know in the micro with
all my crazy Jets ambition.
I can tell you right now and I mean this,
'cause I want you to hear it from me.
My wants around this area
are far more about my legacy
and how I go to sleep at night
than the financial packs.
For me.
I'm so much more driven by legacy.
Legacy is greater than currency.
Let's get in to that
statement a little bit more.
One of my favorite, kind of,
I'm not sure if anybody's
ever said it before,
I'm sure somebody has
but I'm all about it.
What do I mean when I say
legacy is greater than currency?
You know, I always go from self,
inside of myself when I
communicate and talk to people
and that's why I think
I'm able to articulate it
because it's my DNA, right?
So everything I've ever done,
when I first got in to
the liquor store industry
with my dad, all I ever wanted to do
was be the biggest wine shop in the world.
That was the number one agenda.
And so, what I talk about,
every business decision that I ever made,
every one of them was always
based on my longterm legacy
as being the biggest wine
retailer in the world.
That was my entire thought process,
so when I was paying myself nothing
even though the business was exploding
and when I was letting other
managers take vacations
in lieu of my vacation time,
all these decisions, every one of them,
you can't skimp, every one of them
has to be about your longterm legacy.
It can't be about the dollars
you're putting in your pocket.
In this world where things
are changing every minute,
where players are changing every minute,
if you're a hustler, if
you're a very hard worker
and you're putting everything on the line,
put it in to your own personal brand.
Just make rent, pay your bills,
and keep building your personal brand.
And always think of the big picture.
The legacy.
Who are you going to be viewed as
when it's all said and done?
Happy birthday.
- What's this?
Oh my God.
What is that?
- It's a Corzine signed jersey.
- Are you serious?
- Yep.
- Hey, I got something for him.
It's Gary's sneaker in
a rice krispie treat.
- What?
That is so rad.
And the reason I keep pounding
it is because of this.
I truthfully believe all the way
that if every business decision you make,
from hiring a secretary
to what paper you buy,
to every move you make,
if the first question you ask
is how does this effect my legacy,
my longterm legacy,
when it's all said and done
I guarantee the currency
will be there at the end.
The world is changing,
we're more connected.
And your legacy, your maneuvering,
your decision-making process has to start
at your longterm legacy.
Big picture always wins.
And so, if you take
every decision out there
that you can make from who
you're gonna be surrounded by,
who are your friends, right?
People looking for short
term traffic, right?
You know, dig, stumble
upon, this and that,
silly things like that,
or who your circle of friends are
or any of those kinds of decisions,
minor decisions, what
conferences you go to,
what color's your website, everything,
everything has to start with,
how is this going to
impact my global legacy.
And I guarantee you, when
you make legacy decisions
instead of quick cash decisions
or mid range cash decisions,
you're gonna win every time.
When you come from that thought process,
when you add it to the DNA
game that we talked about,
being your DNA, when you add
it to not lying to yourself
and you start putting
these pieces in place,
you start winning.
(gentle, bouncy music)
How ya doing Babbin?
- [Babin] Alright.
- Great.
So bunch of meetings, heading in now.
Chris Bradley say what's up to the vlog.
- What's up vlog?
- Chris Bradley, incredible,
creative at Vayner.
Going in to a big client meeting.
See how it goes.
Did we get anything today?
- [Babin] Very little.
- Sorry vlog.
I kind of like it.
And that's what you need to do.
You need to survive and thrive.
You need to just keep it going,
you know you've got to pay your bills,
see your family, do all
those things, right?
Stay healthy, have a little excess cash
just so you can buy a Wii or
something to make you happy.
But, at all times, all
times eye on the prize.
Legacy is greater than currency.
(mumbles)
All right, going to a Nicks game
with Marc Yudkin, Head Counsel.
Super interesting day,
just got a lot done,
not leaving Babin with a whole, whole lot.
Here's all I can tell you.
When you're in your fucking zone,
when you're doing your thing
you're not scared of anything
even being in the middle of
the road, just walking at it.
You're just not fucking scared.
You're just in your fucking zone
and that's where I'm at right now.
I'm in my fucking zone.
My CEO zone.
My execution zone.
Scared of nothing.
Zero.
Goose egg.
Robert fuckin' Parrish, double zero.
Benoit Benjamin, baby,
for you MBA old school fans.
I'm just feeling great
and I wish you the ability
to be in your fucking zone
where it just all clicks,
you understand all the variables,
you know all the moves, it's the reps.
You've seen it before,
you've seen it before,
you've seen it before.
That's where I'm at.
Please, if anything, after this video,
what is your legacy is
going to be the question
you need to ask yourself
before you make any kind
of financial decision.
Legacy, my friends, is
greater than currency.
(bouncy, playful beat)